I said at the start that OCL had constraints, it had collection classes, and
have navigation. Let's say, let's talk for a minute about the navigation aspect.
I also said that OCL typically is associated with a particular class model
diagram. And when you remember that the, each of the OCL constraints has
a context clause that says which class or operation you are starting with.
Well, it's certainly a value to be able to give constraints on the instances of
a particular class. But it's even more powerful to be able to say, that several
classes are related in certain ways. That means, that in your constraints, you
need to not only be able to specify the attributes of the, the context class.
But the attributes of other classes, as well. Okay? Well, how do you do that?
In OCL, there's the concept of navigation, which allows you to
essentially walk your way through the diagram. And every time you take a step,
you add the period and the name of the next class or relationship along the way.